oh you want price point 70 to 85 kind of just coming in maybe a little bit higher than the
perfect 10 lotions and then we do still want to keep it price conscious for that demographic
awesome i love that great job i must say i absolutely love the packaging on this
And the fact that you show that it has, like, the little beads in it, so showing the customer what kind of burst they're going to get, I love.
And then I got a question.
Since you're going towards that younger fruit, like that 18 and older, do you have any type of shimmer, or what kind of look is it going to have?
Didn't want to add too much of that, so.
So just a little bit of mica, just enough for that, like, super cute sun-kissed glow, or enough with, like, ooh, you're going to see the glitter.
I don't want to go too glittery because we want to make sure it's still wear and go.
Not night clubbing glimmer.
Wear and still go back to the office.
Now, and you just have delayed DHA, no instant natural bronzers?
I'd like to see an immediate bronzer as well.
Okay, so now on color level of that immediate bronzer, is it just going to be a little bit
or are you like looking towards making this like a darker brown in color?
I noticed on the image, it looks almost like a light peachy brown with a tan.
Very, very light.
I love that.
I mean, this is, I think this is great.
Alright, so I have a question.
Getting a lot of nostalgia vibes, like I feel like you're pulling from something that you
loved before.
Correct.
So what, outside of the bees, what was your inspiration for this product?
We just kind of melted everything together of the things that we've missed.
it's so interesting actually just sitting in the prep room over there looking at all the lotion on
the shelves and seeing all the things that have come through and all the things that we've missed
over the years i didn't see ganja on there but that's kind of where our inspiration came from
and that the airless pump with i know we've had a lot of them over the years but the ambrosia and
seeing your product through the bottle was always so captivating you always knew exactly what you
were getting and mixing it together as opposed to popping the beads so we just kind of went a little
bit a little different direction for that so i'm sensing maybe you have a brand you'd like to see
it might um and going back to the like this is a very sensory lotion obviously you're playing show
and tell with the product yes so give us um a little bit more of a description on the pineapple
mango and your inspiration for that fragrance because we're doing show-and-tell with the beads so I want to be like pulled into the center of this product so give me a little bit more on this fragrance so pineapple mango again going back to the fruity pebbles now obviously we're not having the blues and that but if you look at the packaging and you're seeing that orange and yellow that's kind of where our pineapple and mango is coming from you're kind of seeing it and feeling it and then we're going to smell it
one more question here is this a product that we can build on like do you see this like having
more in the collection absolutely full collection cherry cherry hi i have to agree with all the
fellow judges do you all agree this is a fabulous product yeah yeah so in your description of this
product you started i felt that you were very you're leaning more skin care than tanning almost
right can you tell me a little bit about why you feel that that that's your lead
not necessarily more skin care we just want to have them together the younger
generation are becoming more conscious of their skin a lot earlier I know when
I tanned as youth we certainly didn't think at all about our skin what would
happen when we were older and now I feel like skin care so prominent in makeup at
such a young age so every time you know we as manufacturers are developing new
products we usually call it like NPD or a new product development because we're
trying to find a void or a hole in the market and we're trying to fill that why
what hole in the market are we filling with this product I think we're meeting
that evolving customer demand it brings innovation and an aesthetic appeal with
skincare as well kind of meshing it all together I like that I'm gonna blow a
little holes in this for you. Okay. I want to sample this product. How am I going to sample
this product? You mean like in a sample like a packet? Yes. How would I sample this? I don't
think there's any reason that can't go in a packet. Okay. I think there's room for it. I
believe we had a product called Jade and it had DHA bursting beads and I believe it also
came available on a sample so in that packet would you have one side maybe clear to see these beads
and the other side for your ingredients and everything i don't think so i think we can go
solid packet we're always going to have the bottle on the shelf and that's what we're going to sell
from okay good i like it and i'm going to tell you something i'm going to buy so when it comes
out i'll be in line well i really want to pitch to you are we done with questions well sherry i'm
I was going to say, is there anyone downstairs that might have any questions?
No?
All right, Sherry, do you have any quick follow-up?
Yeah, we have a celebrity to endorse our product.
We really think Hailey Bieber is our girl.
Hailey Bieber as a celeb endorsing makeup.
No makeup, natural glowy skin.
She's our girl.
Thank you, Sherry.
A huge round of applause, please.
Anybody here remember that product from back in the day?
That just ages us right there.
I have a personal best
in the salon selling that product. I didn't hear you, sorry.
I love it so much. It's in the museum. Perfect.
You can have a look at it. Alright, so our next pitch contestant
I'm going to bring up Brooke, and I don't know how to say your last name.
Oh, the scores, oh my gosh.
They're going to do their scoring at the end.
The audience is going to do their scoring at the end.
Do you guys have a score?
You can score at the end.
No, no, do you have a score for sharing?
Okay, put it on your whiteboard.
All right, for those of you who can't see as well,
I will read off the scores for you, but our judges have done their score tallies.
We forgot to give the markers for the whiteboards.
Can you just mimic the score?
All right, Brandon, it looks like you've got a score in place.
I do, I do.
That's a permanent marker.
All right, I have a score.
All right, Brandon, what's your score?
I'm going 95.
95.
95 out of 100.
We've got Mr. Generous.
We thought he was beautiful.
Didn't you want to be Mr. Wonderful?
That ship sailed.
We thought you were Mr. Generous.
That's excellent. And Jess?
A 94.
Jacob, you got yours ready?
I'm an 87.
An 87.
A little tougher over here.
He's a bit of a Mark Cuban, this guy.
Michaela?
Are you ready to roll?
We've got an 88, an 86.
Good score.
Good score, good start.
Good job.
Great start.
Something to call home about.
Yep.
Next up, we have Brooke.
I need that newspaper.
Your back.
Next up, we have Brooke.
And is it Pettinger?
Yes.
Pettinger.
Okay, excellent.
So, our second presenter, Brooke Pettinger, is an employee of Miami Glow.
She brought her fans.
You've got 120 seconds to wow us Brooke, please tell us about your product.
Hi everyone, I'm Brooke, an employee at Miami Glow Tanning in Brantford.
I'm excited to introduce to you Head to Toe, featuring Miami Glow.
A luxury all-in-one tanning and skincare created to be my absolute dream product.
I truly believe it could become the dream product for so many others as well.
In an industry full of one noted formulas, Head to Toe steps in as an ultimate multitasker.
Where most products make you choose spray tan or UV, primer or extender, face tape or body only, skincare or bronzer.
This product says, why not all of it?
This is a sleek, sensual glow system designed to elevate every phase of the tanning ritual from prep to finish, from salon to shelf.
It's a conversation starter, a loyalty builder, and a luxury icon in the making.
Let's talk about the fragrance.
It's called Coconut Fresh.
It's a soft tropical sun drenched, a scent that feels like warm skin, a salty breeze and a champagne at the sunset of Miami coast.
It's more than just a fragrance, it's your passport to paradise.
The texture is just as indulgent, a weightless satin that melts into the skin with zero residue.
It hydrates, smooths and leaves your skin kissed by stardust.
To build the full glow ritual, we image pairing it with a pre-tan exfoliating scrub, either sugar based or enzyme powered.
to gently prep the skin without stripping color.
This product is made for the moderate glow getter, anyone aged 18 and up,
all skin tones, all genders.
It's perfect for the self-care enthusiast, the skin care savvy client,
the tattoo trendsetter, and the beauty minimalist who still wants to maximize the results.
Now let's break it down to what powers the glow.
Triple dip technology, which makes the product a spray tan primer,
a UV accelerator, and a light therapy enhancer all in one.
Plant-based bronzers that are streak-free, pore-safe, and face-friendly.
Tattoo technology to lock in color and vibrancy.
Collagen and microbiome balancers to plump, firm, and protect the skin barrier.
Dermadurk, which helps enhance melanin production even without sunlight.
White tea extract, a powerful antioxidant and moisture magnet.
And the soothing and toning technology so your glow looks sculpted and not just shiny.
The price point is $280, and here's why.
This is the bottle that replaces five separate products, a primer, bronzer, moisturizer, light enhancer, and aftercare.
It's not just a lotion, it's a clinical skincare that meets celestial beauty, a real investment in results, and not just a luxury splurge.
Now let's just talk about the name Miami Glow.
It's not based on the scent of the J-Love perfume inspired that came from the name itself.
My boss named her salon Miami Glow because of the iconic fragrance, and this product was created to tribute that same energy.
Just like J Loves Herself, the formula is versatile, safe for the face and body, bold,
works with UV, spray tan, red light and blue light, ageless thanks to collagen, and stage
ready with smoothing and toning and tattoo technology.
The vibe word for this brand is celestial because it isn't just a tanning, it's orbiting
a whole new kind of beauty.
The biggest creative challenge is designing one product to replace many without ever compromising
on luxury performance or skin safety this bottle belongs in luxury spas tanning
swans glow bars and skincare lounges anywhere with that aesthetic meets
performance in anywhere glow is currency and finally the launch head-to-toe
featuring Miami glow should be introduced in spring equinox March 21st
the moment the perfect balance between light and dark the symbolic return of
glow and the time first break just in time for spring break summer prep and
seasonal season of radiance so from light to sun and glow to the moon this is your all-in-one
tanning and skincare ritual before before during and after your tan light up every inch of your
skin with confident skincare and stardust there thank you for that that's amazing um i got like
goosebumps i love the idea of the spring equinox so cool i'm going to tighten the judges up a
little bit this time i want you each to ask one burning question with a follow-up if you need to
too. All right. So Brandon, you start first this time. First of all, Miami guy, love the
Miami glow. Um, you know, you, you said JLo and she, she's always down in Miami. Why am
I going to buy this? You know, when I walk into this salon, $280, right? I think we all
can agree. Very expensive. Okay. Yeah, that's like 50 bucks. We're good. But what, what
What is it going to be sitting on?
Because this is going to be the most expensive product out.
Why am I going to be gravitated?
Because no one working at the salon is going to be able to say all the points that you did.
So how is this going to resonate when I walk into the salon and I need that product?
It's your typical all-in-one.
So a lot of the time when we are at the salon, we talk about facial bronzers,
or light bronzers as well as spray tan, everything that we have, like red light and blue light.
and this just isn't an intensifier for all of it so you would you would put
this at the top of all the products at this along there's nothing as good as
this yes well done all right a couple questions for you outside of the head to
toe story and the multi use of it what are the two hero ingredients that stand
out that you would pitch to your customers to give it that kind of skin
I would say the collagen, which helps with keeping no fine lines, wrinkles, all of that.
And then the microbiome balancer, which just helps with killing any type of bacteria on the skin.
Now, since this is a two-toe product, I have a question about just the viscosity of the product.
Is it thicker? Is it thinner? Is it light? What is the feel of it?
because like me personally my body i want something thicker because for me i feel like oh
yeah i want it super moisturizing but on my face i don't want that no so for me i like the thinner
based lotions where i find that's where i get a lot more of the moisture and i find i get more
use out of the bottle as well and i find that you can just use that all over your body and quick
follow-up question is this going to be super soft on the skin and if so um are we talking velvety
or just like gentle absolutely so it's more like a satin against the skin um that's where the
collagen comes in collagen really makes your skin really satiny and soft i love it uh brooke that
was one of the coolest best pitches and i it's been a while since i've been to miami globe but
you obviously know your stuff so hats off and round of applause like like modern world
Look at him, world's currency, passport of paradise,
business startup, like just, you named all of us
and all the words, it just made me feel like yeah,
like I really wanted this and I needed this product.
So how do you, when designing this product,
or you guys when designing this product,
how did you want people to feel?
I want them to feel like they have it all.
I want them to feel beautiful,
I want them to feel confident,
and I want them to absolutely love the product.
Amazing, I love that answer.
and great price point. I'm a fan. Big, big, big fan.
I was literally blown away the whole
pitch. I was like, that's literally insane.
I'd probably buy it just by you saying that.
Just by
having worked in a salon at one point,
what
would
you still be carrying facial
products and other products as well?
Absolutely.
How would you go about selling those
included if this is
a normal product? Just because of course
for your salon, you do want to maximize all of those sales.
Yeah, so if they didn't go with what I'm performing,
I would show them just your regular tanning lotion,
and then I would talk to them about a facial tanner
and the importance of it.
You shouldn't put any typical body lotion on your face
just because it can clog the pores and make you break out.
So that's when I would state that.
Perfect.
You're killing it, girl.
Thank you.
Thank you, Brooke.
Huge round of applause.
That was awesome.
I'm just going to get the judges here to get their scores calculated.
Anyone else have any follow-up or questions before our friend's away?
Who's got a first score for me?
I didn't know I was this tough of a judge.
I know.
All right.
Gina and I are thinking alike.
You ready, Gina?
I've been 47 years in the tanning industry.
You've got a pair of eights.
Okay.
A pair of eights.
A lot of eights.
And an 86 from Jess.
A 91 from Mr. Generous.
And a 94 from Michaela. Amazing. Thank you guys.
Our third presenter. I remember I used to be able to do this job without glasses on.
Our third presenter is Daniella. Daniella, please join us.
Daniella is an employee at Malibu Beach Tanning in Niagara Falls, Ontario.
Alright Daniella, please give us your highlight reel.
What is your pitch on your product in two minutes or less?
Hello, good afternoon everybody. I'm Daniella from Malibu Beach Tandem. Does your 9-5 have your skin looking pale and dull? Well, this lotion is for you. This 45x DHA bronzer has skin-complementing color, giving you immediate bronze results along with imperfection blurring, giving you an instant hue to your skin and it continues to develop even after your long day is done, giving you gratification of longevity of the color you achieve with each day.
tanning session. With its plush silicone complex, this will have your skin feeling hydrated
and supple. Also a great way to keep those tattoos prominent with its coffee and coconut
scent. A key ingredient, caffeine and coffee seed, along with charcoal beads, work to awaken
those senses and your skin to bring vitality to dull, lifeless skin. This can be used on
your body but also safe for your delicate facial skin so your face can also reap the skincare
benefits and color too the charcoal beads will help clarify detoxify and revitalize this facial
skin this will be sold for 1.65 a bottle and can be found in your local tanning salons the
encapsulated charcoal beads will not clog the pores on the face but they will help revitalize
Some helpful ingredients like water, silicone, niacinamide, which is a personal favorite, DHA, walnut extract, vitamin E, peptides, caramel, coffee, and coconut oil.
Anyone that wants to treat themselves and their skin to a beautiful skin care regimen that allows them to achieve the best color possible with each and every tanning session.
Canadian made, the market needs this product because it's not too dark, not too light.
It gives you the color you are looking for when you are working and you're taking time to tan
to treat yourself to give your skin the best care and love it needs.
Tanning is an investment, so why not invest in a lotion that checks off all the boxes?
Not to mention, you can not only use this on your body, but also mention the face,
and you're reaping all the skin care benefits. Thank you.
A round of applause.
The competitors really came here to bring it today.
you guys have some really really creative ideas i love it there's an actual sample yes danielle
brought a sample of what she wants her product to look and smell like and she's taunting the
judges with that right now which is an excellent idea coffee beans and all i just want to eat it
yeah all right michaela you're ready with a question i am well first i just have to say
it was an amazing pitch and the fact that you brought a sample i literally wrote sample hard
Right at the top of my paper and it can bounce for me.
I just had a question about the charcoal beads you said, right?
Yes.
So you did say it's safe for the face.
Would those charcoal beads absorb or would they be more of an exfoliant charcoal bead,
if you will?
They will burst upon circular motion.
Okay.
And would they leave almost like an immediate color on the face as well?
Perfect.
Can you use your mic please, Danielle, when you're answering?
I'm sorry.
Alright, yes, so the charcoal beads will be burst into the skin once they're stuck in motion into the skin.
Yeah, I love the positioning of this product. I love the color, the charcoal, the coffee kind of theme throughout the whole thing.
The lid, I don't know if you can see it, looks like a little coffee bean. I think it's super, super, super cute.
Thank you.
Just curious, if you were to have a celebrity behind and endorse this product, who do you think that would be?
I was thinking more of the lines of Sofia Vergara.
And yes, she would totally sell this if someone asked her what she was using on her skin and
said that, they would probably buy it.
So I absolutely love that you flat out, you're like, and it's Canadian made baby.
I love it.
The smell, wow.
But now I have a question, since this is a facial product as well, how high is that DHA?
Are we extreme, are we just faintly, just giving a little?
It's mid-range because it's on the facial skin.
Yes, so about 45.
Great job.
As a coffee fanatic myself, but I gotta ask you,
outside of the bottle, and of course the sample,
check, check, check, love, love, love.
Thank you.
She put a heart, I put a check.
I was like, yep, all right.
I love the fragrance too, but obviously the bottle,
the fragrance, coffee, but what's the story
with coffee in this product?
like obviously want it to hit so talk a little bit about like is there coffee and if so what is it
doing for my scale what's the story with it what's the sales pitch on that so it's definitely
awakening your senses um this is just a personal um touch everything i would want in a lotion just
putting it out there just to awaken your senses and just awaken the skin as soon as lotion goes
on the skin it will just give you the next level of confidence good stuff I
think we all love the coffee I love the fragrance for those of you that haven't
seen the sample it's up here fragrance is absolutely amazing when when I buy
I'm going to want to buy it a second time, but why?
I mean, when I use this product, I leave the salon, besides color,
what's my emotional connection in this product to buy it a second time?
The investment to buy it a second time is because how it leaves your skin feeling
and the longevity of color.
So you're going to know the prominent color, the tattoo protection,
the plethora of skin care that is in it.
you would want to be a repeat customer
because it checks off all the boxes.
Okay, and you said fragrance was
of course the coffee fragrance
and you said a little coconut as well.
Have you thought of a third note, maybe a citrus
so when I'm done tanning
I don't have that heavy fragrance because at the end
if you have a vanilla or a citrus
that's the takeaway fragrance.
So if you haven't, you may want to think about
that third note.
Okay, good to know.
But you can also pair it with a tan extender
afterwards.
Anything with collagen in it, collagen banking, just to help move the collagen along the whole
skin care process.
Love it.
I want to drink it now.
Thank you.
Amazing.
Thank you, Daniela.
You drowned the buzz.
Our final two pitches.
Our fourth presenter.
Oh, sorry, judges.
Are you guys that quick this time?
You don't need the Jeopardy music?
We're getting it anyway.
All right.
All right, Gina's got it.
Two from Jess, and an 87 from Mr. Wonderful himself.
Awesome.
Okay, our fourth presenter is Nicole DiBello.
Nicole is an employee at Peaches and Dreams.
She also brought a fan club, and she's got a little something-something to pass out to the judges.
I don't know up here they're looking to get a little bit more wild I don't think it's potent
enough for them all right so Nicole what is your core message you've had some wonderful pitches
today we want to hear you sizzle us short and sharp tell us all about your product
Let's be honest, who has time for a five-step body routine anymore?
Cleanser, shave gel, tan prep, aftercare, it's way too much.
Exactly. That's why we created Radiant Glow Body Wash, your all-in-one luxury solution that does it all in one simple step.
This is not your average body wash. Radiant Glow is a cleanser, shave minimizer, pH balancer, and a sunless tan primer wrapped into one silky formula.
And the scent. It's clean, it's breezy, beach vibe, like fresh air, soft waves, and sunshine, all in a bottle.
The texture is unreal. It lathers up luxuriously, leaving your skin soft, smooth, and ready to glow.
And it's packed with skincare heroes, like aloe vera, green tea, chamomile, and even caffeine to firm and energize.
We made this for everyone 16 and up because glowing skin shouldn't have an age limit.
This broader reach helps more people enjoy real results.
And since prepping your skin is a key for a long-lasting tan, Radiant Glow helps your sunless tan go on smoother and last longer.
At just $49, it replaces multiple products saving you time, space, and money.
You'll find it on boutique shelves, spas, counters, and Lux Beauty Isles.
Our dream ambassador, Chrissy Teigen, obviously. Bold, radiant, and real, just like us.
Yes. Radiant Glow by Beaches and Dreams. Cleanse, smooth, glow, luxury in every drop.
Wow. Practice much? Best pitch. Best pitch. You guys did fantastic. And I'm going to say
gutsy move with a wash, right? I mean, we all know how hard they are to sell, but you
sold me on this one. I think the fragrance, because we got another sample. You know, when
When you hit florals sometimes, it can be your mom or your grandma's fragrance, right?
Florals can be tough.
This is money.
This is very light.
It's airy.
The fragrance, I don't even really have questions.
I just got comments here.
What would make me want to buy this rather than the product I currently have from Sephora that I might be buying?
Because it's new.
Nobody has a product like this.
And time is money.
People are busy.
I know myself.
I'm a busy mom.
sometimes I'm going from soccer practice to home to baseball practice and in
between I'm like I need a spray tan oh crap I don't have time to shave shower
exfoliate I want to do it in the salon sink here we go I've got a product I can do
it all don't tell the boss I do that sometimes very good very good first up
the sales fact she was an awesome touch helps us understand the story because
obviously at first impression it could just seem like a body wash so obviously
you guys did a really good job at conveying that with us so same thing we got a lot of good comments
now I want to go back to this I think at $49 love the concept of multifunctional but do you
guys see this being something that you could like pair together with like a promo item and
a show if so what item would you pair together with it to help cushion that price yeah I think
that we could pair it with our versus spot I think we could pair it with other sunless products that
we have on the shelf and even expand it to other aftercare products right like there's a whole
Wide range of products that you could pair this with, but I don't think there's just one specific one that, you know, we could find, but I think there's a great opportunity for it.
What would you bundle this with specifically? Is there another product that you really care that you could see bundled together?
Um, a moisturizer.
Yeah, combination moisturizer, probably one that would be similar fragrance that would be more unisex for both men and women would be the aloe and ocean.